[Music]
[Music]
god damn it maverick
[Music]
thank you very much matt for what i
assume is a very beautiful rendition
because i don't know what that song is
supposed to sound like because i may
have seen top gun
once or twice but under the age of 12.
so i probably
won't watch the new one
and
what's so annoying
for every one of these goddamn remakes
that you you're not an obsessive fan of
the original is that throughout it's
hey
hey childhood you remember when we did
this last time
remem remember how much you liked it
well we're gonna we're gonna do it again
didn't you like it that we did it again
so i i i just assume that that song is
part of this it is like it's not just in
top gun top gun
is about 25
song
about 50
aerial combat and about another 25 like
low-key homoeroticism thinly masked by a
heterosexual plot yeah i'm picturing
lots of montage behind that song oh yeah
we need a montage well if
that's uh there's a little bit hint
there's a little bit of a way of
expressing this point which is that
anytime you hear that so
the actual homosexual energy in the
movie is being expressed usually by
these men fighting with one another
since they can't actually consummate
their love the way that they want to uh
he's stuck with a boring old woman for
most of the movie
but in the air with his bros
that's where the real love can come
through well it's funny you say that
because
like i said i've i think i watched it
twice but it the image there's two
images that are imprinted
on my mind from the movie and one of
them is when he flies upside down
on top of
i guess a russian plane but the other
scene that imprinted itself in my
pre-pubescent mind and maybe this
explains a lot is that
really horny beach volleyball again it's
not bad like it's not one of those
movies that i would say is so bad it's
good it's got like real production
values it's reasonably well directed
um
the acting is fine in it it's definitely
like the most 80s movie you'll see
though like it's right up there with
commando
terminator
mostly just like a lot of schwarzenegger
rambo all those kind of things and top
gun is what like the
the
[Music]
the gayest straight film you could watch
it is the song signifies the
displacement of desire because it's very
clear that
tom cruise wants to get it on with at
least a couple of the men
but obviously it's the reagan era it
can't do that so he has to settle for
boring old women instead uh
are they in the navy are they navy
pilots by any chance or air force
they fly off of aircraft carriers i'm
not actually sure if they're in the navy
or the air force all i know is that they
fly jets real good
and apparently he does the same in the
sequel so homosociality channeled
through acceptable
venues like warfare
have you seen the new one is it is the
new one even out
yeah it is it's and it's number one at
the box off not just number one it's a
massive like marvel scale hit made
hundreds of millions of dollars opening
weekend so let's see right now this is
why i pitched this episode the number
one tv show in the world in the world is
an 80s revival show the number one song
in a lot of places is an 80s hit
based upon that tv revival and the
number one movie is a sequel to a movie
that came out in the 1980s decades later
uh with the original cast i guess the
listeners can now guess what we're going
to talk about because what comes to mind
when you think of that song top gun
yuppies
counterculture
blade runner
well before we get
maybe too far into this i should say hi
to them
greetings listener and welcome back to
the pill pod as you can probably guess
matt chose the topic of the day
which is
80s
revival slash nostalgia slash the
structure of desire
which will be fun
i don't know i feel a bit out of my
depth i don't feel
nostalgia for the 80s
i don't know that i like the 80s
particularly as compared to other
decades
and other than
like metallica i i i would struggle to
try to come up with a song that came
from the 80s besides like thriller
thriller is 70s i think how fast
it was the 1980s michael jackson was it
okay i thought it was i thought it was
maybe late 70s
you're thinking of off the wall which is
an album he released in the 1970s
you know plenty of songs from the 80s
you just don't know that they were made
in the 80s but like there's so many
songs it's confusing with music too
because they last so long sometimes like
no that isn't that isn't what i meant
like i know born in the usa was probably
in the 80s born in the usa is probably
david bowie defines the 80s but he
started way before
so many classic david songs so much
mcdonald's
madonna
youtube so much michael jackson kate
bush
yeah i mean to clarify there are
certainly songs that i know that are
from the 80s but i do not know
that they are from the 80s i probably
heard them in like
movie soundtracks and [ __ ] like that
whereas like the only albums that i know
from the 80s are
are really just ride the lightning and
master of puppets
def leppard i mean have you never sat
there and listened to pour some sugar on
me yeah no
although i think you sang it at karaoke
before that's like a [ __ ] 80s tune if
there was one
break the batter
if we're talking about our desire being
carried back to the 80s mine has never
has been i don't think i like anything
about the 80s
really you've never seen terminator tell
me come on if you haven't seen
terminator then terminator is a far
better movie it is a far better movie i
agree but like the first one is still
pretty aliens you know yeah but it took
us we had to be done farting around
in the 80s for the true greats to emerge
deftones
nirvana
limp bizkit oh god that's the first one
that comes from that's the first thing
that comes to mind that's so funny
rolling rolling rolling wait was that
was that even 90s
yeah it was it was well no some of it
was early 2000s that's 90s though
we're getting ahead of ourselves now
what what inspired this episode today
there's a lot of 80s nostalgia coming
out and netflix and all sorts of venues
like that right we've got stranger
things we've got cobra kai coming out
the karate kid there's a lot going on
yeah lots of examples to go to and i
think what i want to stress here is
we're talking about a specific imaginary
rehabilitation
of a version of the 80s rather than the
80s themselves
i so when i said to my partner that
we're gonna do 80s nostalgia she said um
oh you got it all wrong the 90s is
what's cool right now and i was like oh
[ __ ] okay i can't keep track of it all
we're all products of the 80s are we not
we're all no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no no no you are right that people keep
predicting that at some point we're
going to firmly enter into like 90s
nostalgia mode but it keeps on both men
i think yeah we're kind of in a
penumbral period where this year like
the 80s has one out last year like the
90s was probably dominant and eventually
we're just going to move smoothly into
90s nostalgia but we're still in like
that weird
liminal zone where we haven't quite
decided culturally i think will smith
and the so-called slap that was heard
around the world uh kind of prevented
the 90s nostalgia wave complete because
when i think of 90s i'm like all fresh
prince of bel-air everything that they
wear in that show is just pure 90s
fashion it's like the 80s but then
everyone went colorblind and started
dressing with all this color
well this is the problem with zoomers
defining taste is they just see the past
as this one
it's like bergson's pure past
they just selectively pull things from
it and now they're making taste i've
seen people wearing baggy jeans again
like it's cool no no no
and i think that might be part of it
also because
yeah
gen x right now is still in charge of
most of the culture productions think
like the are they the duffer brothers
yeah but like they're starting to lose
they're start they're starting to lose
out to us it's only a matter of time and
when we come to power firmly and aren't
scone in the halls of the cultural
industry obviously we're just going to
produce endless amounts of 90 schlock
and remix but the thing is we're never
going to have we're not we're never
going to have the disposable income that
the gen xers do that's true
though in terms of pandering to us i'm
waiting for what is
surely at this point an inevitability
because they're just leaving ip on the
table but that is the fight club remake
or the fight club
uh
paramount plus
series because you know that has to
happen though the chances that are worth
watching are are very very slim we don't
need to remake good things what we need
to remake a schlock that can be like
endlessly regurgitated and recycled for
a new genre we need to remake fight club
to be uh like the new like woke version
of fight club that takes away all the
toxic masculinity oh my god gender
inclusive fight club
exactly exactly what is that an
imaginary
man beating the [ __ ] out of a woman in a
parking lot but later we find out that
she just beat the [ __ ] out of herself
imagine that week on the internet
as we uh as we millennials move into the
positions of uh dominance in society i
believe the 90s will come back exactly
but right now it seems to be gen xers
and they bring with them the 80s and the
whole uh
what like i'm not going to try and
define what the 80s is in a few
sentences but all that is coming back
because it's the it's the 10xers right
now i can t
wall street coke reagan trump yeah
exactly what i really like what i really
like about the 80s like i would would
say that i actually have like some 80s
nostalgia even though i was born in the
80s and don't really remember them
but um what i like about it is like
pretending music although it's so the
music although it's so like a lot of
it's so cheesy oh yeah um i i like what
i like about some of the pop music in
that time is just the way they were
experimenting with synthesizers and drum
machines in a way that would like go on
to influence like a lot of pop music
today and like you can tell how like the
way that they do it it's just so zany
and i like the experimentation actually
my my group of friends often still
like uh kind of like it began as just
sort of for jokes like we play a lot of
80s hits when we were like at cottage at
cottage um
parties and stuff like that just because
there's like something fun about like
the use of drums the use of synthesizers
and in fact
to this day like some of my kind of
more contemporary like favorite bands
that i like listening to are kind of
like 80s style pop synth bands like fm
84 or like something i forget something
83 like they make these these are
instrumentals and sometimes
vocals with like that 80s reverb which
like maybe we can play a clip or
something where like the voice just
sounds really echoey that was so classic
in the
[Music]
and 80s bands like there's a couple
bands right now they're like almost
reproducing music like that
oh yeah so i'm sympathetic to that stuff
i also really like john hughes movies
that's my other favorite thing from the
80s like you know breakfast club and
like uh
and like ferris bueller's day off and
all those movies are like great i
actually recently re-watched and that's
another thing that's had a long
long shelf life like i mean
the mcu the marvel cinematic universe
has made no secret about the fact that a
lot of the younger heroes are
consciously modeled off of john hughes
characters i mean first you had
spider-man where
john wants the director basically said
yeah i'm doing a john
john hughes movies set in high school
except you know with a superhero and
then i think ms marvel is coming out now
and they said exactly the same thing
like oh john hughes you know she's young
she's trying to make her way in the
world yeah that kind of thing
can i ask y'all this is a theory podcast
where does uh
theory fit in we got we got hauntology
we could talk about we could talk about
pastiche or we just our episode on
post-modernism with leotard's book is
basically i mean he published it in 79
but okay i would say like alien came out
that year too right so if post-modernism
no i think yet your short definition was
really good you have reagan
cocaine
and
steven spielberg movies if those were if
you needed three things from the 80s
greed is good
well ship would be good too also so
there's four you got all those and the
wolf of wall street came out about it oh
god about a decade ago now [ __ ] them old
no
i i think i can understand at least a
part of the appeal from a kind of
conservative standpoint though because
one of the things about reactionary
nostalgia is it does almost invariably
tend to operate in waves of about 30
years so when reagan was in power one of
the major promises that he put forward
pretty consistently was a return to ike
you know the eisenhower era
which at that point was presented as you
know the kind of great moment in america
where it defeated all its enemies it
occupied about fifty percent of the
world economy or so and everybody had a
job and women didn't have to go into the
workplace so traditional masculinity was
upheld and everybody kind of knew their
place in the american world order and
that makes a lot of sense because a big
chunk of
not only our nostalgia for the 80s but
the nostalgia that was actually present
in the 80s was for the 50s right you had
you had movies like greece which came
out just before the 80s but whatever the
outsiders a lot of
sochs and greasers you had a lot of
those kind of movies coming out pining
back for the
60s well pre-60s even because right
because the 80s was the neoliberal
revolution so there's a big turn around
from you know the welfare state towards
a neoliberal kind of setup so
they built their own cultural
constellation of references and
i don't know what that means for us
today now that we're sort of reviving
the 80s in a certain way through
marvel and
stranger things
you can see that very blatantly not
necessarily with nostalgia for reaganism
because i think that brand is too toxic
for anybody except for the trump is to
really appeal to putting all that aside
though you definitely still the same
kind of nostalgia for a world that's
conceived as comparatively solid where
the geopolitics yes we're afraid but at
least we we're internally uh committed
uh to our belief systems uh where you
see characters who are morally
comparatively unambiguous right you
don't really see a lot of moral
ambiguity and things like stranger
things shopkins well this speaks to
i mean i completely disagree with you
about the 80s
own self-conception because the 80s
uh represents to me the vigilante
whereas the vigilante used to be you
know the cowboy on the frontier the 80s
features for the first time the
vigilante as a cop and the cop
is trying to fight against the system
because you know the system's getting
nothing done so you have the rebellious
cop
uh death wish i think the death death
wish was a little bit earlier but the
the the die hard
above the law i mean it's right there in
the name you do have this moral
ambiguity but the
the fear is that the system will get
nothing done so we need these
these individuals to step outside of the
system and take matters into their own
hands if we want criminality to be
punished
though matt i i do agree with you that
the the resurgence of what we're seeing
is basically that the childhood 80s it's
you know
remaking e.t through stranger things
or
remaking it which is you know kids
running around and playing in their
neighborhood yeah
absolutely and i think that's a
recurring theme on a lot of 80s
blockbusters quite frankly uh where
there's usually this pristine community
uh that's perceived as being largely
without flaw
until
either some intrusive other comes in uh
like it you know the clown
and disrupts the harmony of that
community uh or
to the extent that it is willing to be
socially critical it's always in a way
that's very removed from reality so take
e.t right uh you have an alien that's
being mistreated by the government uh
but it's not a living person it's not
anything that we could recognize as
comparable to our political reality it's
literally an alien from outer space that
people just want to study right so
there's a kind of uncritical
component to a lot of the films that are
produced in the era and i think
that's also something that people pine
back to again the innocent quality of
them
so look i i'm coming i'm coming to a
thesis here i think on the spot sort of
if we split 80s movie
movies culture media culture into on the
one hand we have the pastoral the safe
space
the suburb
uh white people pretty much and then on
the other hand we have the big city
which is full of criminality and gangs
that that half of it is expressed in
dystopian futures you know the system
can't do anything and this coincides
historically with the dismantling of the
welfare state in the 80s and the
dystopian sci-fi of the 80s is all these
city images uh blade runner
which i think
yeah robocop which i think you could say
expresses a a popular anxiety of
suburban america towards urban america
but right now
the popular remakes of the popul the
revival of the 80s is the revival only
of that suburban america as seen on
screen and there might be there might be
uh
counter examples but we reproduce their
fantasy and their anxiety
um maybe we have a similar one it's
remember the good old days in the
pasture
where we were safe
we had our little group of quirky
friends and our biggest problem in life
was the jocks that bullied us that's
that's what's being remade yeah i think
you're up that's a really good point
yeah because if you look at a lot of
these suburbia small town films with a
few exceptions and i mean we're speaking
very general terms they do tend to
follow the model that i was talking
about where either they're perfect an
innovator comes in and disrupts that or
uh there is some mistreatment
usually of
a kind of fantastic creature
or another
by the government but it's not the
problem with a small town it's somebody
who's coming from afar like the fbi the
g-men uh who don't share the kind of
homie values the people living in that
town and so they bring with them they're
kind of smarmy elitist attitude but most
of the city movies i could think of in
the 80s like terminator
or
blade runner the one that eric brought
up they do have this kind of topic
yeah great example like judge dread
quality also
yeah that's 90s that's 90s
for sure getting our it's getting our
decades and you're you're brushing under
like the the loss of the welfare state
you're brushing under the crack epidemic
you're brushing off like
the the i think new york went bankrupt i
think that was 70s it was like 76 or so
but new york went bankrupt
after that yeah so it's like uh those
problems are set in the future
but then our reproduction now i mean
based on the few examples that we've
given i'm sure there's others but the
reproduction now is not of
that the the problem cities
are futuristic whereas our nostalgia
goes back to small town america yeah
that is really interesting that makes me
want to say
like
there's there's a kind of resistance to
go back
to those sort of sci-fi dystopias and
and sort of or even just the sci-fi
movies that kind of imagine themselves
in the future there's a
kind of resistance to going back and
seeing how we actually
have fallen very short of their visions
of the future back then like if you go
back to blade runner and movie some of
those movies are absurdly soon in their
visions too or like blade runners like
2020 or something like that like it's
gonna be all like that so even if you go
back to the jetsons i'm pretty sure they
thought it was going to be like that by
the 90s or something like that right
like absurdly soon to reach that level
of development but there's a certain
resistance to going back and looking at
how we've not met those expectations and
so we just go back to the small town
examples instead and be like oh look how
things used to be used to be so cute and
quaint yeah i find it i find it
interesting that this is co because it's
it's like safe space
being invaded
by the alien other and in
some cases it's a literal alien
uh in other cases it's it you know these
each of these including the stranger
things they're they're biking around
free
their parents don't know where they are
and it's okay because it's safe here but
then
there's this foreign element
an alien sometimes the government in
other cases
that is uh breaking into
the safe space and i wonder if that's
coded as uh something else i don't want
to speculate too hard
but
it's interesting that that is being
reproduced now and i kind of
wonder why it might just be
simply that you know the directors
remember their childhood like that as a
simpler time but it also might be
some sort of deeper coded anxiety about
our our safe pastoral
homey space being invaded by this other
or that other or the government or you
could code it racially maybe
whatever it is it's interesting though
that it's being reproduced like that now
one of the things it's like you know the
way that this nostalgia is kind of it's
like a fantasy but earlier we were kind
of talking about
the like you know the 80s was this time
of reagan and the financialization and
pills said well that's like no or maybe
it was eric you know no one remembers
that and i think that's actually linked
to like the the way that this nostalgia
is so uh fantasy oriented because
obviously like all that bad stuff needs
to be like excised right it's like no
one's gonna remember so not only for
like do we just well part of it's just
that we remember the images right like
we think about like the neon colors the
bright lights the like you know the hair
metal bands the fashion right so it's
like image-based fantasy
but but
but then
so so obviously like what would be the
first thing to like be removed would be
like
you know the the sort of like structural
inequalities that were behind the scenes
of that right like that wouldn't be
contained in the fantasy clearly um so
that's i was just going to kind of add
to that point before well jamison had a
really interesting thesis in his book um
archaeology is the future a dream called
utopia
where he pointed out that the 1980s was
the last movement you genuinely saw a
domestic insurrectionary uh aesthetic
emerge uh interestingly enough he says
it's cyberpunk right particularly in
things like blade runner or neuromancer
there's this real anxiety about where
the future was going and he thinks
that's in part because there still were
all political and social alternatives
out there so it wasn't like the victory
uh of neo-liberalism and capitalism was
complete right they're still just
worried that things might go abroad or
things might go skew but there was also
the possibility that things could
improve that there was a utopian future
that would look very different available
to us
through a change in relation to
technology and he says that once the
1980s goes away along with the class of
the soviet union amongst other social
factors cyberpunk itself becomes
commercialized and you never really see
another genuinely insurrectionary
aesthetic emerge
or to the extent that they are they do
appear they're almost always
commercialized and banalized immediately
and i do think there is something legit
to that criticism because
think take uh
take robocop for example right uh
robocop is a fantastic movie and it
basically predicts a future where
giant corporations have taken over the
city of detroit which has become a
massive hellhole uh nominally these
corporations are committed to getting
rid of the drug trade but of course we
found out later on that they're deeply
linked with the gangsters who are
running the drug trade be part because
they want to fuel use the fuel and anger
that's generated by the uh spread of
drugs in order to convince the people to
pay for more cops and more expensive
forms of cops it's a very very
subversive very angry film in a lot of
ways and it's hard to think of something
that
has really innovated upon that ecstatic
approach since then in some place i
think in a way they're saying they're
saying we're like the past of this
future in a way is the message in those
sorts of visions
but we'll never get any after 1989 1991
the the fall of the soviet union will
never get
imagining a future like
the man in high castle or something like
that where it could go in a totally
different direction it's it's we we're
foreclosing different kinds of futures
as we move into
the actual future
can you think of a better bookmark for
this than back to the future which came
out in the 80s because in the first part
they go back to the 60s and the 60s is
this kind of pastoralized
you know you got the bullies you got the
nerds you got whatever
and it's kind of safe and then in the
other i think it's part three back to
the future
uh he goes
to the future that the bully controls
and then it again becomes this dystopian
urban
nightmare
because uh oh you're thinking of part
two part three is when he goes the old
ones part two
when biff controls it because he gets
the sports betting book
um then it turns into exactly like
another
blade runner urban scenario
so maybe you have that anxiety expressed
of like where is
where is this going
with these
corrupt
bullies in charge and how do we get back
to what we're safe with which is
you know for the 80s
small town
school dance hokey smoky
[ __ ]
yeah absolutely because i mean
one of the things and this is kind of
jameson's points that really comes up in
these cyberpunk dystopias and i suppose
you could see back to the future too
it's kind of echoing that in a certain
way is a real resistance both to the
anxiety of communist totalitarianism but
also an anxiety about where responses to
communist totalitarianism might take the
united states right as it becomes
increasingly jingoistic increasingly
plutocratic and increasingly ra divided
by race drugs and other things
and
there is at least the prospect that
there's something seriously wrong that
something needs to change dramatically
in a revolutionary sense and
it's hard to see that in definitely a
lot of 1990s and 2000s films i'd say
that maybe there's a little bit more of
that right now once you enter the kind
of end of history period because
all that's foreclosed and
in that sense you can also talk about a
different kind of 80s nostalgia which is
again for the counter cultural
dimensions of it uh that disappeared
culture jamming was big
and uh
writing writing like built writing on
billboards changing advertisements into
a kind of ironic opposite message
the culture jamming oh yeah but it was
essentially like
almost like a
anti-consumerist because when we think
of the 80s right we should think of
materialism and consumerism as becoming
primary cultural
foundations of of america and the world
at that time
and and culture jamming and
ad busting and all that was about you
know disrupting that
materialistic consumerist behavior by
writing something iron some ironic
message on already existing
advertisement is almost like what banksy
does
but
to advertisements instead of just you
know
quasi-vandalism it was quasi-vandalism
with a anti-consumerist message
eric i was thinking when you were
talking earlier we haven't really talked
about
the capitalization
that occurred during the 80s and
i think someone mentioned wolf of wall
street already but one of the
we have these dystopian
future
uh really advanced technology images
and i wonder if there's another thread
to pull on here with
respect to what we talked about last
week
um leota which is the
computerization
of knowledge because the 80s is
also part and parcel with the the
adoption of computers
to
run [ __ ]
and especially
computers running [ __ ] in terms of the
stock market and to make trades a lot
quicker than
i don't know whatever it was that they
were doing before but the
computerization of finance is another
aspect
that
maybe these films are
are sort of an outlet for or they're
they're they're unconscious culturally
thinking what is what are computers
gonna what are the rich going to use
computers for in the future
like how would one write a cultural
history of the 80s today
you'd have to put you know technological
advancement in one place computerization
of finances the invention of
synthesizers and the change of video
games
cgi video games all the technological
stuff on one side because people aren't
nostalgic for that stuff that's
happening behind the curtain people are
nostalgic for the pop culture stuff the
stuff that's on the surface right which
is movies music
fashion those sorts of things right not
people aren't like well reagan was
around when gangster rap came out so i
hate gangster rap like nobody's making
that connection yeah exactly
exactly that's a good point let me float
a little bit of a hypothesis in terms of
nostalgia because the whole point of
nostalgia is not that it's for an actual
time so it wouldn't actually be
for the time of
reagan it would be for the time
when to listen to music you had to open
up a walkman press the eject button put
the tape in the tape ends after
15 songs then you have to flip the tape
over and listen to the other half
because i think
like outside of nostalgia
the zoomers love
uh stranger things i mean it appears
i would i would guess they do
because it's a you know stupid team
drama whatever it is
but oh maybe yeah the the overall
friction or the overall um nostalgic arc
that i might point to if i were trying
to theorize
what it is about the 80s that is very
different from now is the special
effects were bad noticeably bad and that
almost makes them good
uh compared to something like the
avengers because our effects are too
good
they are too
they are too weightless it's like they
have no friction because they just slide
through our movies uh undetected music
has no friction you just put it on your
phone you listen to it endlessly there's
no there's no tape flipping there's no
be kind please rewind when you're trying
to find a movie like to go to a movie
store you have to use your body to
physically
get to the movie store as opposed to
you know flipping flipping through a
digital screen
so i think if i were to try to mediatize
the the nostalgia it would be
that's the last time that our bodies
mattered that's the last time when you
had to like
uh
consume media in a sense that it delayed
you it wasn't immediate it stopped you
you had to like make choices whereas now
it feels more like a continuous flow a
wash
that uh really demands very little of
you
oh that's a perfect another example the
computerization of knowledge from
leotard is now you don't even have to
choose what to watch it'll just choose
what to watch autoplay
and the music too i've actually
discovered so much music because of uh
because of like whatever that spotify
feature is right where it's just like a
spotify playlist like based on you can
even just choose like five songs
and then based on those five songs it'll
just keep playing music that's like kind
of similar to that and you don't need to
think yeah and i really think there's a
phenomenological dimension to this also
that's associated with the sense of
innocence because to draw upon your
theme
there was a funny meme about this the
other day uh where
somebody was carrying a giant boom box
you know like one of those things that
you actually had to like use two hands
to carry uh you know if you've watched
the movie uh with john cusack you know
how he holds it up there
right there was a real tactility to
sharing music with people then uh and a
real physicality to that that you just
don't have now uh where you can share
music on spotify you can all listen to
it in an independent place even many
hundreds of miles apart uh and say
anything that is the name of the john q
says say anything yeah that's it 1989.
yeah and i think people are nostalgic
for that
tactility uh in their phenomenological
everyday life that we lack now um
because it required a degree of
togetherness and a degree of
physical association that's just not
required by the technologies that we
have available right now
that's interesting because there is an
enormous amount of continuity
in that sense between then and now
but well then what makes the
discontinuity is again like shifts in
i guess like cultural aesthetics and
aesthetic taste
or big shifts but otherwise since the
80s there's been a relative lots of
continuity in that respect of
i guess technologies like that changing
and becoming what you're saying like
less tactile less bringing people
together and more just connecting people
but not necessarily bringing them
together i'll give you another example
that steven spielberg constantly
complains about uh which is the way
blockbuster viewing uh has changed right
that's his [ __ ] fault
yeah yeah no no doubt but i mean there
has been a transition away from the
model he pioneered right because
starting with jaws in 1975 and then star
wars you started to have the advent of
these big special effects driven
blockbusters you know raiders of the
lost ark et all the ones that you
mentioned but there was one thing about
them that's different than what we see
today which is that you had to go and
share that movie with other people at a
theater right if you wanted to watch
jaws or you want to watch star wars then
you went opening night you stood in line
for hours and hours and hours because
you couldn't buy things online and then
you watched it with everyone else and
then you shared and you talked about it
nowadays you know with netflix uh oddly
enough you know the medium to which
stage or things appears you don't have
to do that right a lot of material is
available on demand you can watch it
from the comfort of your home and so
there's not that shared experience of
watching a blockbuster movie together
and some people i think are nostalgic
for that as a kind of communal event
that could
tie a community together
movie lovers or blockbuster levels for a
brief period of time through the
phenomenological experience not just
watching the movie but of sharing it
with other people who are in your
immediate vicinity hell i'm nostalgic
for that and i wasn't even born that
time well that's what i was just gonna
say i think for
for younger people like who grew up in
the 2000s even
they they see these kinds of things
happening on tv and they've actually
never had to experience it probably when
we were coming up you still
yeah of course you did you you had to go
to the theater with your friends when
the big the big movie came out and
that's your body physically going to a
place
yeah go to a video
store to rent a movie old jumbo video or
something like that yeah you had to
fight over which one you were gonna
watch because the new releases cost it a
lot more than you guys seen actually
have you guys seen that like uh there's
a great onion video that's like a little
documentary about like and it was
actually made way before netflix was
ubiquitous it's kind of funny like how
like kind of prophetic it was and uh
it's like it's like a it's like a
blockbuster museum and it like shows
guests going there and it's like this is
a time when people had to
go and they lived in such a difficult
time it's like was the movie gonna be
there did somebody else already take it
out and then it's like they have
re-enactors who are like bluff
blockbuster employees and they're like
we have the movie but our only copy has
been checked out and it's just like do
you guys remember this i don't know i
bet our listeners don't but it's netflix
started as like vending machines
yeah for
when they get rid of that i think there
were dvds
it wasn't vending machines it was uh it
was mail it was mail dvds it was dvd but
they had the vending machines where you
could you had to bring it back to after
you rewinded it oh yeah yeah like a
drop-off box i think no no i think you
could just mail them back like if i'm
not mistaken they would send you new
movies every month
and then they would send you back an
envelope to send back the old ones
to our zoomer listeners know if you do
actually want to experience blockbuster
in its full glory there is a way you can
do it uh find a duty or blu-ray uh get
his friend get their friend really
really really really stoned and
go up to them and ask them what they
think about that movie uh and that'll
more or less give you ninety percent of
what it was like to go to a blockbuster
so i just talked about with the vhs
tapes too i mean and having i remember
we used to have like a little machine
that was just a vhs rewinder it wasn't
even your vcr it was like a high-speed
rewinder that we would put the movies in
well you've got to save that 50 cents
because if you don't rewind it they
charge you 50 cents on your on your
blockbuster account
exactly exactly
netflix tried to offer uh blockbuster
they were like hey why don't you buy us
and blog poster was like no yours seems
lame you're not going to never take off
nobody's going to let happen movies
remotely what the hell is that
the funny thing about this nostalgia
though is that you get to experience it
in terms of its imaginary but if you had
an a b choice about whether you go to
the movie store every time you want to
watch something no no one would pick
that but i think it also speaks to what
matt was bringing up this lost
phenomenology that we kind of know is
something that's lost even if you didn't
live through it we know it's not there
now
and i mean i've see you see this in
these remake callbacks the way that
they're directed because you know the
director will
zoom directly into the uh person opening
up the walkman
putting the tape in like we have to
really pay attention to this
you know it's it's it's service to our
nostalgia
yeah i'll give a good example of a movie
that i actually like quite a bit which
is the new it remake uh not the it part
two but at part one because you see kind
of signifiers of this in productions
that deliberately hurt back to the 80s
which is the kind of the physical
tactility of life back then i mean what
do you see in e.t
stranger things or the it remake it's
always little kids riding around on
their bicycles through town going to
movie stores going to get ice cream
making tree forts things like that right
and
today you know i'm not trying to sound
old because i actually really like video
games right
there is a sense at least that there
isn't this kind of tactility uh to
childhood any longer which means i think
for a lot of people it's lost a degree
of its innocence
yeah that's that's it it's interesting
that nostalgia does that to you like
it's it's a fantasy like whatever
nostalgia nostalgic retellings of older
decades like the 80s it's fantasy
it's not what it was really like
but it makes us want it
but it's something that we would never
do even if it was an option right like
who would go to blockbuster if it was an
option today nobody would [ __ ] do
that who would go to a back to a world
before cell phones yeah like like but
but we crave that i still remember
calling my friends on the landlines and
their parents or siblings answer be like
hello is johnny there and like
that and
it's nostalgic but you would never do
that but it just some people something
you just
some people love that stuff uh like and
everyone would hate them
yeah no i'm kidding
i can tell you even something though
that
is basically anticipating a lot of the
stuff that we live with today had a bit
more of a tactile and communitarian
quality to it at least uh seen in
hindsight right and i didn't live
through it so that's what i have to say
right you know take my mother for
example right uh my mother will use the
michael jackson example right constantly
talk about how she and her sisters
sat down together to watch tv to watch
michael jackson uh do the moon walk
right um or watch the billie jean video
because
back then you couldn't just watch music
whenever you wanted music videos
whenever you wanted to you had to sit
down and wait because ntv would play it
at a certain time of day and everybody
waited for it right and
i would find that extremely frustrating
i would [ __ ] hate it if i had to sit
there and be like oh so i have to wait
eight hours i have to wait eight minutes
to listen to a song or watch a music
video that i want this is unacceptable
but
for her
nostalgically remembering the times
where they all anticipated these things
together is something that
you know she cherishes as a memory and
you can kind of see why again because
there's a physicality to it there's a
communal dimension to it
there's a kind of
temporal anticipation uh that you don't
have nowadays that can somehow make the
spirits seem more special all that stuff
is not necessarily lost but hard to
replicate that's why when you're when
you're listening to the radio you have
to call the radio station and ask for
the song and if you get through then you
have your finger on the record button on
the tape deck so you can record it and
that's how you get a song
yeah or do you guys remember actually i
saw someone on twitter like ask what was
the last cd you remember purchased do
you guys remember what the last cd was
that you purchased i do offspring
i got spring
arcade fires the suburbs uh it was for a
girl i was dating at that point because
i liked it a lot and i was like here
this is some canadian music she was
british she'll enjoy it and she [ __ ]
hated it she was like this is trash what
do you feel to be a t2
i was like oh we're gonna have problems
then
what about you eric do you remember god
i can't i i don't know if i can remember
maybe it's some obscure artist named
tallest man on earth i can't i can't
remember interesting the one the most
clear one was hot dog flavored water
limp biscuit obviously oh nice
my
mine i can't remember which one was last
but the two that i remember is either
like the beastie boys anthology which
was like an anthology of their music
that came out i think in like 99 or 2000
and then
grammy rap nominees 1999 which is a
great uh collection of like classic late
90s rap
when you're a kid getting your hands on
one of those like warning label cds
and i remember like that was i mean that
was 99 or 2000 so
and the reason i think like i stopped
buying cds after that is because my dad
was like a super early adopter of cd
burners
like i don't know if you remember when
those were coming out so like i just
started burning all my music and like
stuff like uh like in in 2000 2001.
i got a i the reason i stopped buying
cds was because limewire or no it was
napster then limewire napster yeah but
then i got an mp3 player that held
20 songs
if you reduce the quality to like 192
kilobits a second but if it was at 300
kilobits a second it only held like 12
songs oh man so i did reload it before
school in the morning
so it's like i mean it was like an album
you could just basically fit an album on
there that's not bad though yeah the 80s
came back to kill napster though
metallica sued them
oh yeah
oh it was it was all uh reverse
nostalgia tile effort a futile effort
oh yeah what are you stopping the seas
of change
there's nothing more rock and roll or
more punk than sitting there being like
hey that's our music and if you dare to
listen to it without us getting
royalties then we're gonna sick an army
of lawyers on you
[ __ ] metal
yeah exactly you wanted something really
dark season three of stranger things
started to demonstrate a new kind of
nostalgia uh which is
nostalgia for the 1980s mall culture
since malls are disappearing everywhere
so the whole thing is set at star court
and it kind of made me think a little
bit like yeah this was really the kind
of heyday of the
the mega mall right where you would go
you would gather you would shop for
sometimes the entire day you would eat
you could even go in some of the bigger
ones
to ride right you know they'd have those
big slides or whatever it happens to be
you know all that's disappearing now
and it's interesting because
when i started you know studying
critical theory malls were kind of held
up as these kind of temples of
consumerism neoliberalism uh and avarice
right and exploitation and now it seems
that people have found a way to
give a nostalgic dimension to the
experience of going to a mall uh well
they became so irrelevant as soon as
something becomes irrelevant i feel like
it's it's subject to nostalgia right
it's like
yeah it's like no one cares about them
all anymore yeah i mean like when was
the last time somebody sent you a text
message being like hey let's go shopping
together we're gonna go to the eaton
center and we're gonna wander around for
the entire day
yeah just doesn't happen sounds like a
[ __ ] nightmare it does yeah i mean uh
yeah the mall is kind of funny that way
um yeah i was thinking also that i mean
i know we're talking about like the 80s
and stuff but you know i feel like this
transition point
away from like experience like embodied
experiences right i feel like we've been
on this trajectory like in some ways
since the 80s the computerization of
everything and you know we've been we've
been edging towards that direction
through the 90s and then accelerated
obviously into the 2000s and i feel like
now covet is really like the thing
that that i feel like is gonna i predict
that it's gonna be looked back upon as
like this transition point uh like not
necessarily because of like the disease
but just because of how it forced us to
really like go all in on the
computerization of like work
of shopping
like you know before covet like you
could always do the shopping that way
you could you know you could you could
meet online if you wanted to
i think i probably said like in one of
our earlier episodes earlier in the
pandemic that like one of the things i
kind of liked is sometimes when i was
like too busy at home and a student
would want to meet with me i would
suggest occasionally i'd be like well
could we just skype like i don't really
have time to come to campus right now
and students would often be like oh
that's weird like i don't know like i'll
just wait for another day and like now
it's been so normalized like like for i
forever now i'm sure
like that's just going to be the norm
and like so that's like just one example
of something that like even though the
technology existed
for whatever reason we still had the
like habit of like preferring like the
embodied
engagement like we were only kind of we
only kind of had one foot into like the
stream of full computerization and
coveted in a way was like okay well
these technologies are now like all
available
and it's like now we're kind of forced
to use them and like now i feel like
both feet are in and i think like we're
going to look back on on it as like a
real a real
the like kind of last push towards that
hey and this podcast is a embodiment of
that
most of our first episodes were in
person and
we've done one since
true very [ __ ] up our in person [ __ ]
up our dnd games yeah eric didn't we we
tried
one time playing online and uh never
again i spent a lot of time writing that
campaign too but yeah i know i but i
mean i i thought of it too because like
you know even with malls like i think
yeah of course like nobody but like but
i would sometimes i mean even like
before the pan am there was like times
occasionally when i'd be like okay well
i guess i'll have to like go like when i
need new clothes i'm like i guess i'll
just have to like go and you know try
something on
but then i realized like a lot of these
like during the pandemic a lot of these
clothing stores started just being like
you know free returns like like they'll
pay for like the return label so i was
like okay well [ __ ] i'll just like buy
clothes on online now and like i don't
know the last time i went to the eaton
center it's like why would i bother
going it's like the worst you know i
and jamison brings up our little eaton
center
i mean it's not little it's [ __ ] huge
but if jamison brings up our eaton
center as an example of
post-modernity because the space is so
anti-human
because it gives no like course to the
body it's so tall
it's uh like this giant
massive cathedral
and how much more i hate the ian center
yeah yeah i don't think anyone likes the
eating center tour it's like a tourist
so bad but anyway literally i saw sorry
i'm sorry i just quickly i saw someone
tweet like a list of things like
checklist of like stuff to do in canada
if you're visiting oh i thought the
eaton center was on there and i was like
why the [ __ ] is the eaton center what a
stupid idea
that ottawa was just its own category
like nothing of the stuff in ottawa
ottawa was just like something to check
off the list and i was like [ __ ] you're
putting this yeah but i mean that's
fairly accurate it's it's own category
but if
jameson is saying the eaton center is an
inhuman space how much more is the
computer an inhuman space it's it's an
acceleratedly
in human space that's very true this
actually is bringing me back to
something i've been thinking about quite
a bit lately which is my my own
interpretation of marxism because the
big objection to marxism is that it ends
in class war but it's not actually
class war it's the interests of
people versus the interests of capital
and i definitely think that's a better
reading
if there is a conflict to be had it's
not really between
person versus person
it's really between capital and human
and whatever vestigial interest we have
in the human and why it matters as we
become increasingly marginalized
according to the functioning of the
world and i think i think you're
definitely on to something or correct
that we'll bet we'll look back at the
covid times as an accelerant towards
whatever whatever shape that conflict
ultimately takes if it takes one at all
of course you're telling me i have to go
buy my own groceries that's interesting
i mean there's a part of me there
there's a there's a part of me that
agrees like that that there is something
more inhuman for sure i mean i mean i
think that's
that's doubtless but like more inhuman
than the incident i mean i don't know
because there's there's another way in
which like maybe i'm just weird but like
the convenience factor like is
convenience inherently inhuman like
because you know to some extent i feel
like okay like now that i'm freed from
like the inconvenience of having to go
to [ __ ] h m or something or like
uniqlo to go shop for clothes
and like you know i'm gonna that's gonna
be like three hours of my day now it's
like i go online and like i just choose
clothing and it takes me like maybe half
an hour max if i'm really taking my time
like going through looking at stuff i
know the convenience is there but that's
the thing that everyone is returning to
in the in the film like
stranger things at least the beginning
of stranger things
they made no like the whole point was
zoom in on the walkman like holy [ __ ]
that's a walkman look at this beautiful
artifact of the what's
what's the connection to humanity right
like do you think there's something the
body more humane about inconvenience the
body so the body
okay so but i don't know like like i
mean i i know what you mean like like
there's a way i'm sympathetic to it but
i guess the reason why i want to resist
it a little bit is because i think maybe
what gets undervalued
like because it's like now i have time
to do other things with my body i don't
know it's like it's like it frees me up
like and i can go and like it's like
it's like what's so human about like i
don't know i mean i guess no i shouldn't
have said human i should have said
embodied because it picks up on what we
started with the the
eden center is an anti-body place
because it's just
gargantuan and terrible yeah and
hearkening back to our merlou ponte
series of episodes
and content the the friction that you
deal with the world with with your body
is where you learn stuff and where you
actually produce memory so even a simple
and simple example of that is matt
uh re-articulating what his mom said you
gotta sit in front of the tv for four
hours
waiting for this
video to come on and that's a memory
that she has and i think you can extend
this to
various other places in life where this
friction produces
not just like oh nostalgic memories but
embodied memories where you feel
uh
your inter-subjectivity is dependent on
the world exactly because because i
would say there's there's there's no
place that i feel more alienated and
inhuman than the [ __ ] eaten center of
places like it right so it's like in
some ways it feels more
jarring and more like alienating from
like myself i'm just in this just the
hordes and like this high ceilings and
it's just yeah i don't like that place
at all i would give it a somewhat
different spin right i think there's
definitely a way that you can have a
reactionary approach to convenience
right uh and expediency and say uh that
it's just better for us to go back to a
time period when life was a struggle and
some have actually said that i don't
that's what i mean i don't think we're
actually saying that i think that's why
we're turning it into fantasy into 80s
movies no no i i agree with you i'm just
give me a second i'm going to get to
that i mean you can read dostoevsky's
notes from underground right and that's
one of the things he says if everything
in life was provided for you you'd be
bored and you'd want to smash the
crystal palace uh just for the sake of
smashing it crystal palace being like
the first truly modern building built
for the world expo right uh on the other
hand i think to pills's point uh what
he's talking about isn't necessarily the
fact that what we want to get rid of is
convenience or expediency i think what
he's pointing out
just to speak for you is precisely the
fact that the eaton center isn't really
convenient or really all that expedient
it's there to get you to do one thing uh
which is to shop and consume and not
necessarily enjoy your time there right
or to engage in meaningful
deep human relations and i think if we
were to approach
designing buildings and designing social
spaces from a kind of post-capitalist
standpoint we would still want them to
be very convenient but we would have a
different conception of convenience uh
one that stresses
the human element let's just use you
know pills term rather than i'm
consuming i want to walk that back i
want to walk back human i meant i meant
embodied
i'm not a humanist
sure but you know what i mean you know
more human human space in the sense that
you know it's inviting and encourages
reciprocal relations of some depth uh
and some caliber it doesn't just
incentivize you to move as quickly as
you can through these things but do you
think that that's it is that really the
mall i mean in some ways ironically the
mall was designed to be more convenient
than the alternative before it right
which was that you'd have to go to like
individual stores in your little town
and then you would actually like in a
way that was like the life slowing you
down a little bit because you're like
okay i have to go to the shop the mom
and pop shop right in my neighborhood
like the clothing store and you develop
a relationship with like that clothing
store and like that whatever place and
then now it's like no we're just to
shrink it into one space put it in the
small and everything's there that you
need and you only need to go to that one
place
and there's hordes of people around you
and uh yeah but i think there there
could be ways of rectifying both or to
have a little bit of both of those
things at the same time right and i
think that's part of the issue here
because there is this alienated quality
to going to the eaton center or any mall
right where you're dealing with people
who have
no kind of sense of affect towards you
where you feel
disembodied
in part because no one is acknowledging
your presence or your existence and it's
primarily oriented around getting you to
consume as quickly as possible right and
it's not necessarily designed to get you
to enjoy and relax and to
kind of cultivate yourself at any given
point but
i do agree that you know we don't want
to go back to
some antiquarian system where you have
to walk five miles to go to the corner
store where you'll strike up a
conversation with joe over a cigarette
and you have to walk five miles back
that'd be huge hey i this was the
nostalgia they had in the 80s when they
had to go to the mall they were saying
remember the old mom and pops
those were the days people had real
connection back then
well insofar as the 80s was looking back
at the 50s right the 50s was road
culture like yeah it was just
like like you know whatever jack
kerouac's the road kind of like getting
in your car pay five cents get a full
tank right you go driving the 1980s was
the golden age of them all it was like a
big warehouse if ever just driving which
is driving culture too right because
malls are designed specifically for
drivers right big parking lots that's
the problem with like main streets where
i mean i live on a main street and
actually what i love about it is because
it's like a walking culture right it's
not really or biking right it's not
really a good car culture why because
there's no [ __ ] parking you can't
park anywhere the mall is designed
specifically for car cultures that
everyone can go and park and then go
into the mall right and like
uh exercise
and i like and i like being able to go
to these different stores right here on
danforth avenue right so it's like good
you go shopping there's restaurants
there's arcades in the malls in the
1980s holy [ __ ] i'll give an example
what i was talking about though like
david harvey has spent a lot of time on
this as a kind of marxist geographer
right and this is one of the nice things
i like about his approach to both
designing cities and designing social
spaces is he's not reactionary in the
sense that he says we should go back to
the day of walking five miles to get to
joe's corner store and have a cigarette
with joe and then walk five miles back
but he also doesn't really tend to like
these kind of big post-modern spaces
that
are
deliberately designed to provoke this
disembodied let's just i'll use that
term quality right and just get you
consumed he says you know if you look at
things like um
for instance cooperative spaces or
fairgrounds for example right they are
intended to be convenient to be quick
but also to get you to feel relaxed to
talk to people to
interact with them on a bit more than a
purely exchange basis
now they're not perfect but we could use
these as models to maybe think about how
to design similar spaces when it comes
to things like consumption
or acquisition because why not have a
space uh that marries the best of both
worlds together if we could have it
right and i don't think we've really
achieved that yet uh and i think that a
lot of people want bases like that
because i don't necessarily think that
looking at things from a postcode
viewpoint that we really all just want
to be sitting on our computers
getting whatever it is that we want
however it is that we want but not
interacting with others
i mean i do
i want to avoid as many sales associates
as i possibly can
how can i help you today
can i help you find anything
no please
but i mean that's from our perspective
yeah computers can do that better but
from
a previous perspective right talking to
a human is obviously the best way to get
what you want
talking to someone will go to the store
i when i do sometimes go to the store
i'll go and i'll look and i'll find the
thing that i want and then i'll just go
on my phone to confirm that it's
available online so that i don't have to
interact with anybody
that's not true the main reason is
really just the price it's to be cheaper
online well that's what i was saying
about nostalgia is like the desire for
things that you wouldn't actually want
today we don't want we don't want malls
but we also kind of feel a little bit
you know that's a if you were if you
went to a high school and it was not too
far away from a mall that's probably
where the [ __ ] you hung out and met up
with everybody where the action's
happening
that's where you assembled it's the the
mall that i
went with my
the mall that i was near my high school
it's not there anymore they say you know
it's a strip mall now can't can't afford
to uh
heat and cool these buildings anymore
too much cost
yeah i mean i tend to think nostalgia is
inherently
pretty dumb because it does engage in
this kind of active fantasy the way that
victor does which isn't saying that i'm
immune to it but probably the worst
instance of it isn't really even 80s
nostalgia that's whenever somebody will
sit there and get
nostalgic for their teenage years for
example and if i knew them when i was
teenagers uh they were teenagers i'm
like do you not remember what you were
like like that you were miserable your
girlfriend dumped you uh you had no
money you constantly complained about
your parents and you used to tell me
that you [ __ ] hated life and just
wanted to die so don't give me this
whole thing like being a teenager was
all that great you know every period in
your life has things that suck about it
look towards the future stop looking
towards the past
nostalgia is this uh it's like a
reservoir
of your of your desire though i think
and that's why
now we missed the mall now we missed the
vhs now we missed the arcade now we
missed the walkman i mean i think we
were a little bit too uh
young for arcades because the nes had
come out by the time we were up so
went to internet cafes still even when
you go to the movie theater and there's
some time before the movie you go into
that yeah arcade there right
i guess they still kind of have them but
you're not playing like mortal kombat
and like heroes of might and magic in
there anymore are you playing like
throwing a basketball or like
real real fair games victor we got to
come over to your place and go to the uh
the arcade bar oh yeah the others
there's some good arcade but that's like
a new trend i feel like oh yeah
nostalgia 2.0 is yeah those that's what
you're 2.0 arcade bars all those kids
who couldn't drink when arcades were a
thing it's like now they can drink and
uh then why don't we put those two
things together it's like
and vintage all right they have all the
vintage games it's all vintage exactly
exactly
so we gain something in convenience
which is frictionlessness and then miss
the friction
but again a b choice you're never gonna
go back to
the friction because it's a pain in the
ass few would anyway but i mean is is
there an optimistic note to strike on
nostalgia
because if we think nostalgia
yeah it is fun and if we think it
apart from consumerism and you know it's
just a marketing technique nostalgia is
something that you know
it's something it's a it's like a
positive mental state in a certain way
when it doesn't lead you into
a kind of fantasy detachment
dissociation with current reality it can
be a good thing
but maybe i don't know i don't know i
don't even know how to strike a positive
stance on nostalgia because it's so i'm
so used to thinking of it as a component
of marketing really oh i do i have to go
but i will say that the one good thing
about nostalgia is it means that any
sequel which you did not get that you
wanted will eventually come case in
point i always wanted a good finale to
the x-men 1990s series
and lo and behold it has been willed
into being thirty years later the curse
they're doing a remake of the 90s x-men
series the one with the amazing intros
music so oh that's that is the one thing
you can't be optimistic about from a
culture pop culture standpoint if you
sit there and you think god damn that
series ended and i needed more or i
didn't get a proper ending
it will come don't worry that's a great
that's a great intro music you should
end this episode with uh with that intro
music the x-men animated series that's
wonderful
i got one one thing to say with
nostalgia which is almost always
marketing as i i think matt said it's
almost always marketing but in a sense
it also
fills in the cracks
especially the phenomenological
cracks that we
don't know are there they're kind of
virtual but we feel them
in the accelerated states of
technology and cap yeah like it kind of
has us looking backwards
you know the the whole uh marshall
mcluhan rear view mirror syndrome kind
of thing it has us looking backwards but
it kind of guides us forwards at the
same time
because obviously
nostalgia implies
newness
and return
return of something old but in a new
form in a new way right like this was
the essence of modernism right make it
new
and today we're still with that
it's kind of got the post-modern
elements but we still we still make it
new stranger things
is something new and we i don't know if
our listeners still play dungeons and
dragons if any of them have ever heard
of that or any other tabletop imaginary
games right like this
this might make you want to go back and
do that more and that could be a good
thing because that you know what
dungeons dragons promotes human
interaction
even a shared imagination about
something
it also promotes racial satanic
sacrifice which you know
not the best but if you do have a good
dm
a good d game is better than a video
game
yeah it works parts of your brain that
i'm sure video games do not get at
because video games are very
maybe not as bad as just sitting there
watching the boob tube but
video games are pretty bad tactile
you've got your little figurines you
have to actually use your hands to roll
a dice you're sitting around the same
table video games aren't that bad you
have to imagine you have to act you have
to sympathize empathize you have to put
yourself in somebody else's shoes and i
know it's it's kind of just a cheap
kind of plot device in in
in stranger things but it still kind of
evokes something for me
anyway and i guess d did come out in the
late 70s i think maybe even early 80s
came out
and got imported it got it it was and
then there was a big scare like it was
promoting demon craft which is satanic
panic yeah yeah the satanic panic it
merged in with that and okay all that
but it's still like you get nostalgic
for that sort of thing too because
something
something that
made people scared
back in the day
then filtered through the lens of
nostalgia yeah now it could become a
kind of exciting and
unfor maybe unfortunately maybe not
de-politicized kind of activity to
engage in
it's
pretty terrifying to think that one day
people are going to be looking back at
now nostalgically
well maybe we'll look back at the 2020s
as the the pre-metaverse
era
i don't really buy into that but you
know it could happen
maybe everyone actually knows he never
maybe zuckerberg gets his [ __ ] way
i'm i'm doubtful yeah who knows yeah
i'm doubtful yeah the thesis of this
episode maybe is uh un
indeterminate
indeed
who knows what are we going to imagine
future nostalgia for
this time let me uh let me close on this
question then do we still have if we're
if we're sort of pasteurizing
the suburbs through this uh
or through what we're choosing to
reproduce from the 80s do we still have
pastures or has the internet kind of
destroyed that or is the internet itself
where where our new pastures are
you mean past pastoralizing you keeps it
pasteurizing i'm like i'm like no no no
no no no
like sanitized
fantasy
yeah yeah okay pastoralizing yeah
yeah i mean
i mean it still is in many ways but
because
you know i guess the climate change
stuff now we're thinking yeah maybe like
building car infrastructure dependent
pastors are not the great the greatest
way to pastoralize we still
look back to a time when we didn't have
to think of
carbon emissions as guiding
our decisions yeah if only i think the
reason why the 2000s have has so far
been not very pastoral maybe people will
find things to be uh to like to to think
about in that sense but i think like the
social consciousness of the 2000s has
been very much defined by like looking
at all the consequences of the things
that we do and like feeling bad about
them and like pointing out look how bad
the environment is look how bad this is
look how bad look how many nascent forms
of racism and oppression there are look
how much look at this look at that it's
like you know the whole i feel like the
2000s is like
in some ways like the the the time when
you know the the the critical theory
uh kind of like insights have have bled
into like uh everyday society where
everyone's gonna be a critic about
everything uh and like how and like
that's not a bad thing i'm just saying
like i think the the 90s still had a
kind of like blissful ignorance about
certain things even though that
consciousness raising was was beginning
i mean if you lived in a suburb yeah
yeah yeah of course of course i have to
critique you because we're in the age of
christian
2020 is the age of critique
uh yeah if only we're true it's all it's
all relative now
well boys i think that's it i think the
80s are dead and we should let
dead dogs lie
enjoy this outro
peace out
[Music]
foreign
[Music]